voici pierpoljak
bonsoir ça va ça peut aller ouais ça
peut aller ouais meilleur album reggae
groove rappelé l'histoire de la musique
pour pierpoljak
donc aujourd'hui vous avez beaucoup de
succès 1 c'est la grosse benne son nom
vous l'avez là j'en ai une il dit je
m'éclate en mercedes et c'est pas de
problème parce que quand j'étais dans la
nièvre j'ai été sans voiture j'ai eu le
rmi et j'ai fait les trois huit dans une
usine de biscottes donc merde maintenant
je me paye la benz entre trois normales
vous vivez ça comment le succès l'argent
c'est bien par exemple vous avez déclaré
parfois vous parler des succès vite
parfois tu en as marre et peut-être que
le jour où ça s'arrête finalement tu es
en banque et tu finis par comprendre
pourquoi les mecs célèbre bye tombe dans
la drogue où ils se suicident vous avez
envie d'arrêter parfois
ça arrive voit alors votre vie elle a
commencé à savigny-sur-orge
la grosse tour verte un roi ni savigny
la grosse tour verte à droite la grâce à
l'autoroute on la voit ensuite il
colombes
or votre père est parti assez tôt de la
maison prête aux tréteaux et comme un
peu la maman de dany boon votre mère a
été obligé de faire des ménages et vous
parlez de votre de ça vous parlez dans
une chanson qui combat vous qu'on va
écouter d'ailleurs qui s'appelle maman
vous dit
j'aurais dû le tuer à l'époque à
l'époque où j'étais assez fou pour le
faire et toute ma vie je vivrai avec ça
avec le départ de mon père c'est vrai
[Musique]
la fois
mme amara
m
tu sais que tu n'es pas vraiment digéré
la vie scolaire
ils étaient dans une zone
dû faire j'sais pas pourquoi [ __ ]
j'ai détesté
tu m'as
toujours
du perche à la main dans les eaux bissau
tu m'as dit que tu dis
alors votre maire s'est battue toute
seule elle vous a toujours soutenu même
quand vous et aller en taule à l'âge de
16 ans je sais que c'est tout
c'est vrai alors une fois vous avez reçu
votre père il est revenue à 1
que vous aviez dix ans et ça s'est mal
passé sap a pu s'arranger
et donc c'est ça qui vous a rendu
non
je suis seul
alors je vais mettre une chose au point
parce que souvent les journalistes
disent que vous avez été skins est en
fait j'avais été plutôt redskins quoi
vivent c'est ouais j'ai été toutes
sortes de choses je suis encore toute
sorte de choses en fait c'est la musique
qui m'emmenait partout j'ai été quoi et
pour pour l'histoire des skinheads
effectivement c c'est ce qui m'a permis
de découvrir le reggae quoi ouais parce
que c'était en alors le reggae music
s'est élevé à londres en fait ouais
j'étais à londres à 15 ans parce que
j'étais un petit punk et j'avais envie
de voir les groupes jouer quoique j'aie
kalaba bien alors en revenant
d'angleterre six mois ferme à fleury il
a alors en cellule vous avez un
compagnon de cellule un guadeloupéen et
ils vous parlent d ir jours j'espère ils
et ce jour il vous parle il vous parle
des îles et des xes libérez vous partez
dans les îles comme ça ça un peu en
dominique effectivement j'ai
rastaman a changé ma vie oui
des gens que j'ai rencontrés en fait qui
que j'admirais quoi j'ai admiré leur
leur façon ils m'ont pas bassiner avec
des doctrines parce qu'on peut pas me
faire ça mais je les admirais parce
qu'ils marchaient droit et j'ai eu envie
d'être comme quoi dire j'étais un petit
voleur et j'ai après ça j'ai essayé
d'être des droits quoi quand vous
retournez en métropole où vous habitez
dans la nièvre j'aimais bien la nièvre
pas ce que vous dites j'aime parce que
y'a rien ni personne c'est ça et votre
femme que martiniquaise et ceci en fait
là on a beaucoup de choses en commun
tous les deux
notamment celle ci quoi on aime beaucoup
la nature et vivre à la campagne ça me
plaît tout les deux quoi à vous cultivez
là-bas en fait vos cultures c'est un
cultivateur moderne complètement donc je
cultive pas seulement de la marijuana
mais aussi des aussi des légumes et
j'essaye de planter en fait ma mère est
une expérience ma mère c'est quelqu'un
qui a la main verte bah oui quoi mais
c'est un jeune fille du n'ya pas
longtemps sur le cannabis soit la
position de libé c'est quoi là dessus
moi je suis pour la dépénalisation de la
consommation pas forcément la couleur
en fait je pense qu'aussi si on si on
commence par la culture ça va ça va
simplifier un peu les choses quoi alors
vous dites tous les rastas ne sont pas
pacifique
c'est vrai que les nous l'image qu'on a
ici des rastas c'est des mecs sympas qui
fume de l'herbe toute la journée qu'ils
sont cools et où ils peuvent être
agressifs je pense que ça c'est une
image
très occidentale en fait
le reggae music et le rastaman il vient
d'un il vient d'un stress ça sort d'un
stress quoi ça veut dire que c'est c'est
la musique d'un peuple qui a été opprimé
qui a été emmené d'afrique par les vers
les antilles en esclavage donc et
et qui plus est c'est une musique aussi
qui vient des ghettos de la jamaïque et
c'est pas ça la vision du
du rasta pacifique
qui fut mais tout ça c'est elle est
fausse je dirais les gens qui ont des
rêves comme ça se casse les dents là bas
et c'est quoi alors le rastafarisme les
gens qui ont le portrait du négus hailé
sélassié dans leur chambre ça fait très
froid le rastafarisme c'est reconnaître
la divinité de l'empereur hailé sélassié
ouais donc le le
l'empereur d'ethiopie le négus culture
lui c'est un grand homme qui a défendu
son pays et c'est pas du tout un
dictateur comme certains peuvent le dire
mais à devenir un dieu je pense que le
rastafarisme c'est une crise d'identité
quoi dudu blackman emmené aux antilles
mais ce que je pense mais moi c'est ma
vision moi je pense aussi que pour être
pour reconnaître la divinité de sela 6
il faut être noir aussi quoi maintenant
je vais te dire quand si tu as un blanc
qui rentre dans le reggae musique en
jamaïque comme moi je le fais
tu viens pas pour révolutionner les
choses quoi ouais sinon elle a pris le
pas leur expliquer c'est des conneries
parce que sinon ça peut mal se terminer
en même temps non sinon t'as rien à
faire là
[Musique]
et
à
l'aller
je
en
page
non
[Musique]
ma
x
[Musique]
mme amara
st
bravo pierpoljak victoires de la musique
alors
j'avais déclaré que finalement le
chanteur français le plus rasta c'était
brassens
c'est un des meilleurs ouais je sais pas
si j'ai dit ça vraiment ah bon c'est
presque en même temps un nom mais
quoique parce que
je peux pas je peux pas me faire prendre
par ce à quoi un ouais mais
je reste pas beaucoup beaucoup cet
homme-là est un
véritable artiste
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux